I think conservatives are a little too
loose with the calls for secession
because secessions do not happen
peacefully they just never do it doesn't
happen in India and Pakistan it doesn't
happen yeah there's no brexit process in
the United States that's right and so
you know unless you're really willing to
go out and kill your cousins which I'm
not I don't think that we we ought to
succeed look I'd love to shrink the
federal government and stop having them
run our lives but to Matt's Point we've
been talking about that for 70 years and
we never do it even when we win
elections because Republicans are
cowardly and there's maybe not even a
way to do it you know it seems to me the
call for secession is ironically sort of
a lib answer you know it's kind of this
idea like you do you and to getting to
your point Matt and Ben about slavery
and the comparison we kill upwards of a
million babies a year in this country so
I think the moral issues are pretty
serious and I don't want to just let
half the country continue to do that and
I don't want to let them do them and
destroy the distinction between male and
female and do all sorts of horrible
things and destroy my country I want to
take the power back